welcome to Horry sorry the channel where
we discussed the latest tech news and
delve into newest tech products so today
we're taking a look at why you should
get your gtx 1100 series card as soon as
possible while supplies last but before
we delve into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you would like to
stay up there with latest tech news
related to gaming and pcs the gtx 1180
has been rumored for a very long time
and there have been very many leaks that
have been popping up but recently there
was a huge leap from gamer MELD who is
supposedly getting his information from
an insider who told him that the gtx
1180 was set to launch on july 30th the
insider also told gamer meld other
details like its price and specs if you
guys are interested in all the details
of that leak then make sure to check out
my dedicated video on it but long story
short the gtx 1180 is going to be a
significant upgrade over the gtx 1080
and even the gtx 980ti
but it is going to be expensive at $700
while this price may seem high this
price is well worth it for the gtx at
1180 based on the performance that we
are expecting based on all the leaks
that we have so far
the GTX 1180 will have very similar raw
horsepower as to the gtx 980ti but
actually be more efficient it will also
come with GDR 6 memory beyond the tall
animator process and be based on new
turning architecture on top of this it
may bring tenser cores and ray tracing
which may be what DirectX 12 point 5 and
DirectX 13 may be all about the new GDD
are 6 memory the new process and a new
architecture itself would give the gtx
1180 a good boost over the gtx 1080p eye
at about 20 frames per second but if the
gtx 1180 does come with ray-tracing
attempts of course then that difference
will be a lot higher but even if that
doesn't happen the gtx 1180 is still
better than gtx 980ti
and as a result its price of $700 is
completely justified because that is the
same price of the gtx 980ti so as a
result by spending the same amount
you're getting more performance so the
price does make sense
on top of this the gtex 1080 also came
out for an MSRP of $700 so this is
nothing new and as a result there's no
reason that you should be worried that
you're overpaying for the gtx 1180 this
it is fairly priced and asked for the
other 1,100 cards all those cards is
supposed to come out for the same MSRP
as their predecessors so there is no
problem there either people have been
waiting many months for these cards to
come out base at the horrible GPU
pricing situation with the 10 series and
as a result they know exactly which car
they want to buy and they are going to
buy it as soon as it comes out because
to a lot of these people money was
really never an issue and they just
didn't want to overpay for a graphics
card and now that there are new graphics
card being offered for MSRP these people
will jump onto it as soon as possible
overall I think that it is clear that
there is a lot of anticipation for the
1100 series especially due to how the
GPU market has been for the last couple
of months and as a result there is high
demand and unfortunately Nvidia probably
won't have enough GPUs to fulfill this
high demand as soon as pre-ordering
starts a lot of people are gonna go and
instantly buy it and this may even lead
to pre-ordering being backed up and
finally once the card is on to the
market you won't be able to find the
card anywhere and it'll be out of stock
in every single retailer and finally
after a week or two after the release
you'll be able to see it on to reach
other side again but the GPU will cost
50 to $100 more than MSRP similar to
what happened at the Intel i7 8700 K so
as a result if you don't buy a GPU as
soon as you can then you may be stuck
waiting for GPU prices to come down
again or simply giving in and overpaying
for them so make sure not to get into a
situation by pre-ordering as soon as you
can
overall there is a lot more demand and
anticipation for the 1100 series over
past releases because of the GPU market
situation and as a result the gtx 1100
series across the board will most likely
go out of stock very soon and shoot up
in price i usually tell you guys to wait
and make well-thought-out decisions but
this is definitely not the time to wait
I know a lot of you guys would like
revue and performance videos of these
new 1100 series cards before you buy
them so that you can choose which one
you really need but if you do this by
the time that you are ready to buy the
price of these new level series cards
will probably be really high or there
simply won't be any stock left so this
is the time to just choose which eleven
or series card you want and just go for
it unless you wanted to deal with all
the problems associated with waiting but
that's just what I think how do you guys
feel about this do you guys think that
Nvidia is prepared to fulfill this high
demand or do you think that Nvidia is
not prepared at all make sure to comment
down below what you guys think because I
do read all my comments and I'm curious
as to what you guys think so make sure
to post your thoughts also if you liked
it together make sure drop a like and
hit that subscribe button if you guys
like to see more videos just like this
one but until next time bye
[Music]